plenty of emotion
smiles and relief the results are in and
after terms of turmoil they've done it
because of the pandemic and we just
missed a lot of stuff and thank god we
had some advanced information to help us
in some places i'm happy with this
i wasn't expecting it
but we pulled through
it's been so hard we've been
missing out on so much learning so it
took a while to like get back on track
but yeah we got there
to help them get there gcse students
were given extra exam information and
here at sir herbert lyon academy in
bletchley they turbo charged the
timetable
we have a superb staff body here who
worked weekends through the holidays
evenings as additional for the children
when they could to make sure that they
didn't miss any content
and i'm very proud of our staff and
children and it's all paid off today
certainly has i couldn't be prouder
those children deserve every success
results were higher than average but
lower than the last two years when covid
cancelled exams no real surprises with
this year's gcse results but there is a
lot of concern about regional
differences and the fact children in
london and the south continue to do
better than children in the north
for example in london 32.6
of results awarded were the top grades
compared to
22.4 percent in the northeast and
yorkshire and the humber
leaders in the north say this deepening
divide must be fixed
what we've seen today
is really concerning we've now got a 10
gap between the highest grades at gcse
between north and south
and that covers not just the northern
regions actually but also is replicated
in the midlands as well that have all
fallen back around 2 compared to where
they were
before the pandemic
the government insists it is a priority
we know at the moment in too many parts
of our country it isn't equal and it
isn't fair that's why we've got the uh
education investment and improvement
areas uh 55 of those around the country
is making a difference but we have been
set back by the pandemic
kovid caused huge disruption for all
students but for many it's left a legacy
of academic inequality and gaps that
will be hard to close laura bundock sky
news bletchley